during the appointment of a special
counsel who sits here before us today
the FBI investigation was marred by
further corruption and bizarre abuses
top DOJ official Bruce or whose own wife
worked on fusion gps's anti-trump
operation feds steals information to the
FBI even after the FBI fired steel the
top FBI investigator and his lover
another top FBI official constantly
texted about how much they hated Trump
and wanted to stop him from being
elected and the entire investigation was
open based not on five eyes intelligence
but on a tip from a foreign politician
about a conversation involving Joseph
Mifsud he's a Maltese diplomat who's
widely portrayed as a Russian agent but
seems to have far more connections with
Western governments including our own
FBI and our own State Department than
with Russia raising li ignoring all
these red flags as well as the
transparent absurdity of the claims they
are making the Democrats have argued for
nearly three years that evidence of
collusion is hidden just around the
corner like the Loch Ness monster they
insist it's there even if no one can
find it consider this in March 2017
Democrats on this committee said they
had more than circumstantial evidence of
collusion but they couldn't reveal it
yet mr. Muller was soon appointed and
they said he would find the collusion
then when no collusion was found in mr.
molars indictments the Democrats said
we'd find it in his final report then
when there was no collusion in the
report we were told Attorney General
Barr was hiding it then when it was
clear Barr wasn't hiding anything
we were told it will be revealed through
a hearing with mr. Muller himself and
now that mr. Muller is here they are
claiming that the collusion has actually
been in his report all along hidden in
plain sight
and they're right there is collusion in
plain sight collusion
between Russia and the Democratic party
the Democrats colluded with Russian
sources to develop the steel dossier and
Russian lawyer natalia vasko skaia
colluded with a dossiers key architect
fusion gps head glenn simpson the
democrats have already admitted both in
interviews and through their usual
anonymous statements to reporters the
today's hearing is not about getting
information at all they said they want
to quote bring the Moller report to life
and create a television moment through
ploys like having mr. Muller recite
passages from his own report in other
words this hearing is political theater
it's a hell Mary attempt to convince the
American people that collusion is real
and that it's concealed in the report
granted that's a strange argument to
make about a report that is public it's
almost like the Democrats prepared
arguments accusing mr. Barr of hiding
the report and didn't bother to update
their claims once he published the
entire thing among congressional
Democrats the Russia investigation was
never about finding the truth it's
always been a simple media operation by
their own accounts this operation
continues in this room today once again
numerous pressing issues this committee
needs to address are put on hold to
indulge the political fantasies of
people who believed it was their destiny
to serve Hillary Clinton's
administration it's time for the curtain
to close on the Russia hoax the
conspiracy theory is dead at some point
I would argue we're gonna have to get
back to work until then I yield back the
balance of my time to ensure fairness
and make sure that our earring is prompt
I know we got a late start director
Muller they're hearing what we
structured as follows each member of the
committee will be afforded five minutes
to ask questions beginning with the
chair and ranking member as chair I will
recognize thereafter an alternating
fashion and descending order of
seniority members of the majority and
minority after each member has asked his
or her questions the ranking member will
be afforded an additional
five minutes and asked questions
followed by the chair will have
additional five questions five minutes
for questions the ranking member and the
chair will not be permitted to delegate
or yield our final round of questions to
any other member after six members of
the majority and six members the
minority have concluded their five
minute rounds of questions we'll take a
five or ten-minute break
we understand you've requested before
resuming the hearing with congressmen's
while well starting his round of
questions special counsel Muller is
accompanied today by Aaron Zeb Lee who
served as deputy special counsel for may
2017 until May 20 19 and had day-to-day
oversight of the special counsels
investigation mr. Muller or mr. Zeb Lee
resigned from the Department of Justice
at the end of May 20 19 when the special
counsels office was closed both mr.
Muller and mr. Zeb Lee will be available
to answer questions today I will be
sworn in consistent with the rules of
the house and the committee mr. Muller
mr. Sibley's appearance today before the
committee is in keeping with the
committee's long-standing practice of
receiving testimony from current or
former Department of Justice and FBI
personnel regarding open and closed
investigative matters as this hearing is
under oath and before we begin your
testimony mr. Muller and Zeb Lee would
you please rise and raise your right
hands to be sworn
or affirm that the testimony you are
about to give at this hearing is the
whole truth and nothing but the truth
thank you
the record will reflect that the
witnesses have been duly sworn ranking
member Thank You mr. chair I just want
to clarify that this is highly unusual
for mr. Zell be to be sworn in we're
here to ask director molar questions
he's here as counsel our sides not going
to be directing any questions to mr. Zeb
Lee and we have concerns about his prior
representation of the Hillary Clinton
campaign aid so I just want to voice
that concern that we do have and we will
not be addressing any questions to mr.
Sibley today I think the ranking member
I realize as probably do mr. zeppeli
that there is a angry man down the
street who's not happy about your being
here today but it is up to this
committee and not anyone else who will
be allowed to be sworn in and testify
and you are welcome as a private citizen
to testify and members may direct their
questions to ever they choose with that
director Muller you are recognized for
any opening remarks you'd like to make
good afternoon chairman Schiff ranking
member Nunez and members of the
committee I testified this morning
before the House Judiciary Committee I
asked that the opening statement I made
before that committee be incorporated
into the record here without objection
Berger I understand that this committee
has a unique jurisdiction and that you
are interested in further understanding
the counterintelligence implications of
our investigation so let me say a word
about how we handled the potential
impact of our investigation on
counterintelligence matters as we
explained in our report the special
counsel regulations effectively gave me
the role of the United States attorney
as a result we structured our
investigation around evidence for
possible
use in prosecution of federal crimes we
did not reach what you would call
counterintelligence conclusions we did
however set up processes in the office
to identify and pass counterintelligence
information on to the FBI members of our
office periodically briefed the FBI
about counterintelligence information in
addition there were agents and analysts
from the FBI who are not on our team but
whose job it was to identify
counterintelligence information in our
files and to and to disseminate that
information to the FBI for these reasons
questions about what the FBI has done
with the counterintelligence information
obtained from our investigation should
be directed to the FBI I also want to
reiterate a few points that I made this
morning I am not making any judgments or
offering opinions about the guilt or
innocence in any pending case it is
unusual for a prosecutor to testify
about a criminal investigation and given
my role as a prosecutor there are
reasons why my testimony will
necessarily be limited first public
testimony could affect several ongoing
matters in some of these matters court
rules or judicial orders limit the
disclosure of information to protect the
fairness of the proceedings and
consistent with long-standing Justice
Department policy it would be
inappropriate for me to comment in any
way that could affect an ongoing manner
second the Justice Department has
asserted privileges concerning
investigative information and decisions
ongoing matters within the Justice
Department and deliberations within our
office
these are Justice Department privileges
that I will respect the department has
released a letter discussing the
restrictions on my testimony but I
therefore will not be able to answer
questions about certain areas that I
know are of public interest
for example I am unable to address
questions about the opening of the FBI's
Russia investigation which occurred
months before my appointment or matters
related to the so-called steel and
dossier
these matters are the subject of ongoing
review by the department any questions
on these topics should therefore be
directed to the FBI or the Justice
Department third as I explained this
morning it is important for me to adhere
to what we wrote in our report the
report contains our findings and
analysis and the reasons for the
decisions we made we stated the results
of our investigation with precision I do
not intend to summarize or describe the
results of our work in a different way
in the course of my testimony today as I
stated in May I also will not comment on
the actions of the Attorney General or
of Congress I was appointed as a
prosecutor and I intend to adhere to
that role and to the department
standards that government finally as I
said this morning over the course of my
career I have seen a number of
challenges to our democracy the Russian
government's efforts to interfere in our
election is among the most serious and I
am sure that the committee agrees now
before we go to questions I want to add
one correction to my testimony this
morning I want to go back to one thing
that was said this morning by mr. Liu
who said and I quote you didn't charge
the president because of the OLC opinion
that is not the correct way to say it as
we say in the report and as I said at
the opening we did not reach a
determination as to whether the
president committed a crime and with
that mr. chairman great answer questions
thank you director Muller I recognize
myself for five minutes dr. Muller your
report describes a sweeping and
systematic effort by Russia to influence
our presidential election is that
correct that is correct and during the
course of this Russian interference in
the election the Russians made
outreach to the Trump campaign did they
not that occurred over the course of
yeah that occurred it's also clear from
your report that during that Russian
outreach to the Trump campaign no one
associated with the Trump campaign ever
called the FBI to report it am i right
I don't know that for sure in fact the
campaign welcomed the Russian help did
they not I think we have really rapport
in our in the report indications that
that occurred yes the president's son
said when he was approached about dirt
on Hillary Clinton that the Trump
campaign would love it that is generally
what was said yes the president himself
called on the Russians to hack Hillary's
emails there was a statement by the
president and now it's general lines
numerous times during the campaign the
president praised the releases of the
Russian hacked emails through WikiLeaks
that way that did occur your report
found that the Trump campaign planned
quote a press strategy communications
campaign and messaging unquote based on
that Russian assistance I am not
familiar with that that language comes
from volume 1 page 54 apart from the
Russians wanting to help Trump win
several individuals associated with the
Trump campaign we're also trying to make
money during the campaign in transition
is that correct that is true Paul
Manafort was trying to make money or
achieve debt forgiveness from a Russian
oligarch generally that is accurate
Michael Flynn was trying to make money
from Turkey true Donald Trump was trying
to make millions from a real estate deal
in Moscow to the extent you're talking
about the the hotel and Moscow yes yes
when your investigation looked into
these matters numerous Trump associates
lied to your team the grand jury and to
Congress number of persons that we
interviewed and our investigation and it
turns out did lawyer Mike Flynn lied he
was convicted of lie yes George
papadopolis was convicted of lying true
Paul Manafort was convicted of lying
true Oh
for it was in fact went so far as to
encourage other people to lie that is
accurate mana Ford's deputy Rick gates
lied that is accurate Michael Cohen the
president's lawyer was indicted for
lying true
he lied to stay on message with the
president allegedly by him and when
Donald Trump called your investigation a
witch-hunt that was also false was it
not like to think so yes well your
investigation is not a witch-hunt is it
is not a witch-hunt
when the president said the Russian
interference was a hoax that was false
wasn't it true when he said it publicly
it was false yeah he did say publicly
that it was false yes and when he told
it to Putin that was false too wasn't it
dad I'm not familiar with when the
president said he had no business
dealings with Russia that was false
wasn't it
I'm not gonna go into the details of the
report that along those lines when the
pressure when the president said he had
no business dealings with Russia in fact
he was seeking to build a Trump Tower in
Moscow was he not I think there there
are some question about when this was
accomplished you would consider a
billion dollar deal to build a tower in
Moscow to be business dealings wouldn't
shoot director Muller yeah absolutely
short your investigation found evidence
that Russia wanted to help Trump win the
election right I think generally that
would be accurate Russia informed
campaign officials of that I'm not
certain - what conversation - you're
referring to him well through an
intermediary then formed Papadopoulos
that they could help with the anonymous
release of stolen emails accurate Russia
committed federal crimes in order to
help Donald Trump when you're talking
about that computer crimes in charge in
our case absolutely
the Trump campaign officials built their
strategy their messaging strategy around
those stolen documents I'm generally
that's true and then they lied to cover
it up but generally that's true thank
you
mr. Nunez thank you welcome director as
a former FBI director you'd agree that
the FBI is the world's most capable law
enforcement agency I would say where yes
the FBI claims the counterintelligence
investigation of the Trump campaign
began on July 31st 2016 but in fact it
began before that in June 2016 before
the investigation officially opened
Trump campaign associates Carter Paige
and Stephen Miller a current Trump
adviser were invited to attend a
symposium at Cambridge University in
July 2016
your office however did not investigate
who is responsible for inviting these
Trump associates to this symposium your
investigators also failed to interview
Stephen Schrag II an American citizen
who helped organize the event and
invited Carter Paige to it is that
correct can you repeat the question
whether or not you interviewed Stephen
shrieky who organized the cambrian nose
areas I am going to stay away from the
first Trump associate to be investigated
was general Flynn many of the
allegations against him stem from false
media reports that he had an affair with
a Cambridge academic swetlana low cover
and that low cover was a Russian spy
some of these allegations were made
public in a 2017 article written by
British intelligence historian
Christopher Andrew your report fails to
reveal how or why Andrew and his
collaborator Richard Dearlove former
head of Britain's mi6 spread these
allegations and you failed to interview
swetlana Lokoja about these matters is
that correct I'm gonna get it and I can
get into those matters to which you
refer you had a team of 19 lawyers 40
agents and an unlimited budget correct
mr. Muller I would not say we had an
unlimited budget let's continue with the
ongoing or the opening of the
investigation supposedly on July 31st
2016
the investigation was not open based on
an official product from five eyes
intelligence but based on a rumor
conveyed by Alexander downer on volume 1
page 89 your report describes him
blandly as a representative of a foreign
government but he was actually a
longtime Australian politician not a
military or intelligence official who
had previously arranged a 25 million
dollar donation to the Clinton
Foundation and has previous ties to
Dearlove so downer conveys a rumor he
supposedly heard about a conversation
between Papadopoulos and joseph Mifsud
James Comey has publicly called Mifsud a
Russian agent yet your report does not
refer to Mifsud as a Russian agent
Mifsud has extensive contacts with
Western governments and the FBI for
example there is a recent photo of him
standing next to Boris Johnson the new
Prime Minister of Great Britain well
we're trying to figure out here mr.
Muller is if our NATO allies or Boris
Johnson have been compromised so we're
trying to figure out Comey says Mifsud
is a Russian agent you do not so is do
you stand by what's in the report I'd
stand by that which is in the report and
not so necessarily with that which is
which is not in the report I want to
return to mr. downer he denies that
Papadopoulos mention anything to him
about Hillary Clinton's emails and in
fact Mifsud denies mentioning to them
pop - that - Papadopoulos he denies that
Papadopoulos mentioned anything to him
about Hillary Clinton's emails and in
fact Mifsud denies mentioning to them -
Papadopoulos in the first place so how
does the FBI know to continually ask
Papadopoulos about Clinton's emails for
the rest of 2016
even more strangely your sentencing memo
on Papadopoulos blames him for hindering
the FBI's ability to potentially detain
or arrest Mifsud
but the truth the truth is Mifsud
waltzed in and out of the United States
in December 2016 the US media could find
him the Italian press found him
and he's a supposed agent at the
epicenter of the purported collusion
conspiracy he's the guy who knows about
Hillary Clinton's emails and that the
Russians have them but the FBI failed to
question him for a half a year after
officially opening the investigation and
then according to Volume one page 193 of
your report once Mifsud finally was
questioned he made false statements to
the FBI but you declined to charge him
is that correct you did not indict mr.
mrs. well I I'm not going to speak to
the series of happenings as you
articulated them but you did not indict
mr. my mother the gentleman has expired
pardon you did not indict mr. mixon true
mr. Himes director Mahler
thank you for your lifetime of service
to this country and thank you for your
perseverance and patience today director
your report opens with two statements of
remarkable clarity and power the first
statement is one that is as of today not
acknowledged by the President of the
United States and that is quote the
Russian government interfered in the
2016 presidential election in sweeping
and systematic fashion
the second statement remains
controversial amongst members of this
body same page on your report and I
quote the Russian government perceived
it would benefit from a trump presidency
and work to secure that outcome do I
have that statement right I believe so
director Muller this attack on our
democracy involved as you said two
operations first a social media
disinformation campaign this was a
targeted campaign to spread false
information on places like Twitter and
Facebook is that correct that's correct
Facebook estimated as per your report
that the Russian fake images reached a
hundred and twenty-six million people is
that correct I believe that's a song
that we record director who did the
Russian social media campaign ultimately
intend to benefit Hillary Clinton or
Donald Trump Donald Trump the second
operation direct they just say Donald
Trump but there
were instances where Hillary Clinton was
subject to much the same behavior the
second operation in the Russian attack
was a scheme what we call the the hack
and dump to steal and release hundreds
of thousands of emails from the
Democratic Party and the Clinton
campaigns at a fair summary that is did
your investigation find that the
releases of the hacked emails were
strategically timed to maximize impact
on the election I'd have to refer you to
the our report on that question
page 36 I quote the release of the
documents were designed in time to
interfere with the 2016 US presidential
election mr. Muller which presidential
candidate was Russia's hacking and
dumping operation designed to benefit
Hillary Clinton or Donald Trump mr.
Trump sarmale is it possible that this
sweeping and systematic effort by Russia
actually had an effect on the outcome of
the presidential election those issues
that being or have been investigated by
other entities 126 million Facebook
impressions fake rallies attacks on
Hillary Clinton's health would you rule
out that it might have had some effect
on the election I'm not gonna speculate
mr. Maloy your report describes a third
avenue of attempted Russian interference
that is the numerous links and contacts
between the Trump campaign and
individuals tied to the Russian
government is that correct
could you repeat that question your
report describes what is called a third
avenue of Russian interference and
that's the links and contacts between
the Trump campaign and individuals tied
to the Russian government let's bring up
slide 1 which is about George
papadopolis and it reads on May 6 2016
10 days after that meeting with Massoud
much discussed today Papadopoulos
suggested to a representative of a
foreign government that the Trump
campaign had received indications from
the Russian government that it could
assist the campaign through the
anonymous release of information that
would be damaging to Hillary Clinton and
director that's exactly what happened
two months later is it not well I can
speak to the excerpt that you have on
the screen as being
right from the report but not the second
half of your question well the second
half just to refer to page six of the
report is that on July 22nd through
WikiLeaks thousands of these emails that
were that were stolen by the Russian
government appeared correct that's on
page six of the report this is the
WikiLeaks posting of those email I can't
find it quickly but I please continue
okay so just to be clear before the
public or the FBI ever knew the Russians
previewed for a Trump campaign official
George papadopolis that they had stolen
emails that they could release
anonymously to help Donald Trump and
hurt Hillary Clinton is that correct I'm
not going to speak to that director
rather than report this contact with
Joseph Mossad and the notion that there
was dirt that the campaign could use
rather than report that to the FBI that
I think most of my constituents would
expect an individual to do Papadopoulos
in fact lied about his Russian contacts
to you is that not correct that's true
we have an election coming up in 2020
director if a campaign receives an offer
of dirt from a foreign individual or a
government generally speaking should
that campaign report those contacts
should be it can't be depending on their
circumstances a crime but I I will yield
back the balance of my time mr. Connolly
Thank You mr. baller did anyone ask you
to exclude anything from your report
that you felt should have been in the
report I don't think so but it's it's
not a small report but don't what ask
you specifically to exclude something
that you believe should have been in
there that you thought that I can recall
well heel the bounce might address
correctly thank you thank the gentleman
for yielding
good afternoon director Muller in your
May 29th press conference and again in
your opening remarks this morning you
made it pretty clear you wanted the
Special Counsel report to speak for
itself you said at your press conference
that that was the off
is final position and we will not
comment on any other conclusions or
hypotheticals about the president now
you spent the last few hours of your
life from Democrats trying to get you to
answer all kinds of hypotheticals about
the president and I expect that it may
continue for the next few hours of your
life
I think you've stayed pretty much true
to what your intent and desire was but I
guess regardless of that the special
counsels office is closed and it has no
continuing jurisdiction or authority so
what would be your authority or
jurisdiction for adding new conclusions
or determinations to the special
council's written report as the latter I
don't know or expect changes in
conclusions that we included in our in
our report so to that point you
addressed one of the issues that that I
needed to which was from your testimony
this morning which some construed as a
change to the written report you talked
about the exchange that you had with
congressman Lew I wrote it down a little
bit different I want to ask you about it
so that the record is perfectly clear I
recorded that he asked you quote the
reason you did not indict Donald Trump
is because of the OLC opinion stating
you cannot indict a sitting president to
which you responded that is correct
that that response is inconsistent I
think you'll agree with your written
report I want to be clear that is not
your intent to change your written
report it is your intent to clarify the
record today as I started today this
afternoon and added either a footnote or
an EndNote what I wanted to clarify is
the fact that we did not make any
determination with regard to culpability
in any way we did not start that process
then down the road terrific thank you
for clarifying the record a stated
purpose of your appointment as special
counsel was to ensure a full and
thorough investigation of the Russian
government efforts to interfere in the
2016 presidential election as part of
that full and thorough investigation
what determination did the Special
Counsel office make about whether the
steal dossier was part of the Russian
government effort
to interfere in the 2016 presidential
election again when it comes to mr.
Steele I defer to the Department of
Justice well first of all director right
I very much agree with your
determination that rough Russia's
efforts were sweeping and systematic I
think it should concern every American
that's why I want to know just how
sweeping and systematic those efforts
were I want to find out if Russia
interfered with our election by
providing false information through
sources to Christopher Steele about a
Trump conspiracy that you determined
didn't exist well I was again I'm not
gonna discuss the issues with regard to
mr. Steele the and in terms of a
portrayal of the conspiracies we
returned two indictments in Computer
Crimes arena one GRU and in other active
measures in which we lay out in
excruciating detail I under and those
two and I gather large conspiracies I
agree with respect to that but why this
is important is an application and three
renewal applications were submitted by
the United States government to spy or
surveil on Trump campaign Carter
associate or Carter page and on all four
occasions the United States government
submitted the steal dossier as a central
piece of evidence with respect to that
now the basic premise of the dossier as
you know was that there was a
well-developed conspiracy of cooperation
between the Trump campaign and the
Russian government but the Special
Counsel investigation didn't establish
any conspiracy correct well what I can
tell you is that the events that you are
characterizing here now it's part of
another matter that is being handled by
the Department of Justice but you did
not establish any conspiracy much less a
well developed one again I pass on
answering that question the special
counsel did not charge Carter page with
anything correct national counsel did
not all right my time has expired
I yield back missile
director Muller I'd like to turn your
attention to the June 9th 2016 Trump
Tower meeting slide 2 which should be on
the screen now is part of an email chain
between Don jr. Don Donald Trump jr. and
a publicist representing the son of a
Russian oligarch the email exchange
ultimately led to the now infamous June
9th 2016 meeting the email from the
publicist to Donald Trump jr. reads in
part the Crown prosecutor of Russia
offered to provide the Trump campaign
with some official documents and
information that would incriminate
Hillary in her dealings with Russia and
is a part of Russia and its government's
support of mr. Trump in this email
Donald Trump jr. is being told that the
Russian government wants to pass along
information which would hurt Hillary
Clinton and help Donald Trump is that
correct that's correct now Trump juniors
response to that email is slide 3 he
said and I quote if it is what you say I
love it especially later in the summer
van dahl jr. invited senior campaign
officials Paul Manafort and Jared
Kushner to the meeting did he not he did
this email exchange is evidence of an
offer of illegal assistance is it not I
cannot adopt that characterization well
isn't it against the law for a
presidential campaign to accept anything
of value from a foreign government
generally speaking yes but they're
generally the cases are circumstan page
184 and volume 1 that the federal
campaign finance law broadly prohibits
foreign nationals from making
contributions etc and then you say that
foreign nationals may not make a
contribution or donation of money or
anything of value it said clearly in the
report itself thank you
now let's turn to what actually happened
at the meeting when Donald Trump jr. and
the others got to the June 9th meeting
they realized that the Russian
delegation didn't have the promised
quote-unquote dirt in fact they got
upset about that did they not generally
yes
you say in volume 1 page 118 that Trump
jr. asked what what are we doing here
what what what do they have on Clinton
and during the meeting Kirchner actually
text mana Ford saying it was quote a
waste of time in quote is that correct I
believe it's in the report along
Alliance you specify so to be clear top
Trump campaign officials learned that
Russia wanted to help Donald Trump's
campaign by giving him dirt on his
opponent Trump jr. said loved it then he
and senior officials held a meeting with
the Russians to try to get that Russian
help but they were disappointed because
the dirt wasn't as good as they had
hoped so to the next step did anyone to
your knowledge in the Trump campaign
ever tell the FBI of this offer mm so
did Donald Trump jr. tell the FBI that
they received in offer of help from
that's about all I'll say on on this
aspect of it wouldn't it be true sir
than if they had reported it to the FBI
or anyone in that campaign during the
course of your two-year investigation
you would have been covered such other I
would hope yes yes sir is it not the
responsibility of political campaigns to
inform the FBI if they receive
information from a foreign government I
would think that that's something they
wouldn't should do well not only did the
campaign not tell the FBI they sought to
hide the existence of the June 9th
meeting for over a year is that not
correct in the general characterization
I would question it if you're referring
to later initiative that flowed from the
media then no what I'm suggesting is
that you've said and volume 2 page 5 on
several occasions the president directed
aides not to publicly disclose the email
setting up the June 8th meters that's
that correct thanks sir given this
illegal assistance by Russians you chose
even given that you did not charge
Donald Trump jr. or any of the other
senior officials with conspiracy is that
right
correct and while you're talking about
if you're talking about other
individuals you're talking about the
attendees yes that's right you know
that's right
so mr. Muller even though it didn't you
didn't charge them with conspiracy don't
you think that the American people would
be concerned that these three senior
campaign officials eagerly sought a
foreign adversaries helped to win
elections and don't you think that
reporting that is important that we
don't set a precedent for future
elections I can't accept that
characterization well listen I think
that it seems like a portrayal of
American values to me sir that someone
with if not being criminal it's
definitely unethical and wrong and I
would think that we would not want to
set a precedent that political campaign
should not divulge of information if
it's foreign governments yes this
Tennessee thank you sir mr Turner mr.
Muller I have your opening statement and
in the beginning of your opening
statement you indicate that pursuant to
Justice Department regulations that you
submitted a confidential report to the
Attorney General at the conclusion of
the investigation what I'd like you to
confirm is the report that you did that
is the subject matter of this hearing
was to the Attorney General yes you also
state in this opening statement that you
threw overboard the word collusion
because it's not a legal term you would
not conclude because collusion was not a
legal term well it depends on how you
want to use the word in the general
parlance people can think of it that way
but if you're talking about in the
criminal statute arena you can't because
some really it's much more accurately
described as conspiracy right so in your
words are it's not a legal term so you
didn't put it in your conclusion correct
that's what you're correct mr. Muller I
want to talk about your powers and
authorities now the Attorney General and
the appointment order gave you powers
and authorities that are reside in the
Attorney General now the Attorney
General has no ability to give you
powers and authority greater than the
powers and an authority of the Attorney
General correct I don't believe I know I
pick that up
it's correct mmm mr. Moore I want to
focus on one word in your report it's a
second to the last word in the report
it's exonerate the report states
accordingly while this report does not
conclude that the president committed a
crime it does not exonerate him now in
the judiciary hearing in your prior
testimony you've already agreed with mr.
Radcliffe that exonerate is not a legal
term but there is not a legal test for
this so I have a question for you mr.
Moore
mr. Muller does the Attorney General
have the power or authority to exonerate
when I'm putting up here is the United
States Code this is where the Attorney
General gets his power and the
Constitution and the annotated vert
cases of these which we've searched we
even went to your law school because I
went to Case Western but I thought maybe
your law school teaches it differently
and we got the criminal law textbook
from your law school mr. Muller nowhere
in these because we had them scanned is
there a process or description on
exonerate there's no office of
exoneration to turn general's office
there's no certificate at the bottom of
his desk mr. Moore would you agree with
me that the Attorney General does not
have the power to exonerate I'm gonna
pass on that why because it embroiled us
in the legal discussion and I'm not
prepared to do a legal discussion in
that arena
well mr. mr. Miller you would you would
not disagree with me when I say that
there is no place that the Attorney
General has the power to exonerate and
he's not been given that authority you
wouldn't and I'm not gonna fight a queue
a question great well the one thing that
I guess is that the Attorney General
probably knows that he can't exonerate
either and and that's the part that kind
of confuses me because if the attorney
Joe doesn't have the power to exonerate
then you don't have the power to
exonerate and I believe he knows he
doesn't have the power to exonerate and
so this is the part that I don't
understand if your report is to the
Attorney General and the Attorney
General doesn't have the power to
exonerate and he does not and he knows
that you do not have that power you
don't have to tell him that you're not
exonerating the president he knows this
already so then that kind of changed the
context no we included in the report for
exactly that reason he may not know it
and he should know it so you believe
the attorney bill Barr believes that
somewhere in the hallways of the
Department of Justice there's an office
of exoneration no that's not what I said
well I believe he knows and I don't
believe you put that in there for for
mr. Barr I think you put that in there
for exactly what I'm gonna discuss next
and that is so the Washington Post
yesterday when speaking of your report
the article said Trump could not be
exonerated of trying to obstruct the
investigation itself Trump could not be
exonerated now that statement is correct
mr. Muller isn't it and that no one can
be exonerated the reporter wrote this
this reporter can't be exonerated mr.
Muller you can't be exonerated in fact
in our criminal justice system there is
no power or authority to exonerate now
this is my concern mr. Muller this is
the headline on all of the news channels
while you were testifying today Muller
Trump was not exonerated now mr. Muller
what you know is that this can't say
Muller exonerated Trump because you
don't have the power or authority to
exonerate Trump you have no more power
to declare him exonerated than you have
the power to declare him an interesting
Cooper so the problem that I have here
is that since there's no one in the
criminal justice system it has a power
the president pardons he doesn't
exonerate courts and juries don't
declare innocent they declare not guilty
they don't even declare exoneration the
statement about exoneration is
misleading and it's meaningless and it
colors this investigation one word out
of the entire portion of your report and
it's a meaningless word that has no
legal meaning and it has colored your
entire room of the gentleman's
experiment mr. Carson Thank You chairman
Thank You director Muller for your years
of service to our country I want to look
more closely sir at the Trump campaign
chairman Paul mana for an individual who
I believe betrayed our country who lied
to a grand jury who tampered with
witnesses and who repeatedly tried to
use his position with the Trump campaign
to make more money let's focus on the
betrayal and greed your investigation
serve found a number of troubling
contacts between mr. Manafort and
Russian individuals during and after the
campaign is that right sir
correct in addition to the June 9th
meeting just discussed mana 4 also met
several times with a man named
Constantine Klimek will the FBI assess
to have ties with Russian Intel agencies
is that right sir correct in fact mr.
mana fork didn't just meet with him he
shared private Trump campaign polling
information with this man linked to
Russian intelligence is that right sir
that is correct and in turn the
information was shared with a Russian
oligarch tied to Vladimir Putin is that
right sir allegedly director Muller
meeting with him wasn't enough sharing
internal polling information wasn't
enough mr. man afford went so far as to
offer this Russian oligarch tide to
Putin a private briefing on the campaign
is that right sir yes sir and finally
mr. man afford also discussed internal
campaign strategy on for battleground
states Michigan Wisconsin Pennsylvania
and Minnesota with the Russian
intelligence linked individual did he
not sir that's reflected in the report
as were the items you listed previously
director Muller based on your decades of
years of experience at the FBI would you
agree sir that it creates a national
security risk when a presidential
campaign chairman shares private polling
information on the American people
private political strategy related to
winning the votes of the American people
and private information about American
battleground states with a foreign
adversary is that the question turn yes
sir
I'm not going to speculate along those
lines to the extent that it's within the
lines of the report and then I support
it
anything beyond that it's not part of
both that which I what support well I
think it does sir I think it shows an
infuriating lack of patriotism from the
very people seeking the highest office
in the land director Muller Manta Ford
didn't share this information in
exchange for nothing did he serve I
can't answer that question without
knowing more about that the question why
it's clearly he hoped to be paid back
money he was old by
Russian or Ukrainian oligarchs in return
for the passage of private campaign
information rather that Israel director
Muller is my colleague mr. heck we'll
discuss later agreed corrupts would you
agree sir that the sharing of private
campaign information in exchange for
money represents a particular kind of
corruption a one that presents a
national security risk to our country
sir
I'm not going applying on that and I
don't have the expertise in that arena
to really apply would you agree sir that
man affords contacts with Russians close
to Vladimir Putin and his efforts to
exchange private information on
Americans for money left him vulnerable
to blackmail by the Russians I think
generally so that would be the case
would you agree sir that these ads
demonstrated a betrayal of the
democratic values of our country rests
on I can't agree with that directed not
that it's not true yes sir dr. Muller
well I can tell you that in my years of
experience as a law enforcement officer
and as a member of Congress fortunate to
serve on the Intel committee I know
enough to say yes trading political
secrets for money with a foreign
adversary can corrupt and it can leave
you open to blackmail and it certainly
represents a betrayal the values
underpinning our democracy I want to
thank you for your service again
director Muller we appreciate you for
coming today I yield back chairman dr.
Wynn strip Thank You mr. chairman Thank
You mr. Muller for being here today
smeller's it accurate to say your
investigation found no evidence that
members of the Trump campaign were
involved in the theft or publication of
Clinton campaign related emails yeah can
you read can you repeat the question is
it accurate to say your investigation
found no evidence that members of the
Trump campaign were involved in the
theft or publication of the Clinton
campaign related emails I don't know I
don't know well well Volume one page 5
the investigation did not establish that
members of the Trump campaign conspired
or coordinated with the Russian
government
it's election interference activities so
it would therefore be an accurate based
on this to describe that finding as open
to doubt that finding being that Trump
campaign was involved with theft or
publication of the Clinton campaign
emails you following that do believe I'm
following it but it is that portion or
that matter it does not fall within our
jurisdiction all right i or base in
which what you your report says volume 1
page 5 I just want to be clear that open
to doubt is how the committee democrats
described this finding in their minority
views to our 2018 report and it kind of
flies in the face of what you have in in
your report but so is it accurate also
to say the investigation found no
documentary evidence that george
papadapolis told anyone affiliated with
the trump campaign about joseph smith's
it's claims that the russians had dirt
on canon and clinton let me turn that
over to mr. Sedley i'd like to ask you
sir this is your report and and that's
what I'm basing this on and then could
you repeat the question for me again
yeah is it accurate to say the
investigation found no documentary
evidence the George papadopolis told
anyone affiliated with the Trump
campaign about Joseph Misfits claims
that the Russians had dirt on Canada
Clinton I believe it appearing in the
report that's accurate okay so yeah in
the report it says no documentary
evidence that Papadopoulos shared this
information with the campaign it's
therefore you inaccurate to conclude
that by the time of the June 9 2016
Trump Tower meeting quote the campaign
was likely already unnoticed via George
papadopolis is contact with Russian
agents that Russia in fact had damaging
information on Trump's opponent would
you say that that is inaccurate to say
that it's it's likely already I direct
you I could direct you to the report
well I appreciate that because the
Democrats jumped to this in contract
incorrect collusion and there
minority views again which contradicts
which you have in in your report
concerned about a number of statements
I'd like you to clarify because a number
of Democrats have made some statements
that I have concerns with and maybe you
can clear them up so a member of this
committee said president Trump was a
Russian agent after your report was
publicly released that statement is not
supported by your report correct that is
accurate not supported multiple Democrat
members have asserted that Paul Manafort
met with Julian Assange in 2016 before
WikiLeaks released DNC emails implying
mana four colluded with the signs
because your report does not mention
finding evidence that mana Ford met with
Assange I would assume that means you
found no evidence of this meeting is
that assumption correct I'm not sure now
I agree with that assumption but you
make no mention of it in your report
would you agree with that yes I would
agree with ok mr. Muller does your
report contain any evidence that
President Trump was enrolled in the
Russian system of compliment as a member
of this committee once claimed what I
can speak to was information evidence
that we picked up as the Special Counsel
and I think that's accurate as far as it
thank you I appreciate that
so let's go for a second to scope did
you ask the Department of Justice to
expand the scope of the special counsels
mandate related to August 2nd 2017 or
August 20th 2017 scoping memoranda well
there without looking at the memoranda I
could not answer that well let me ask it
did you ever make a request to expand
your office's mandate which at all
generally yes and was that ever denied
I'm not gonna speak to that you're not
goes through our internal deliberations
well I'm just trying to understand
process as expanding the scope come from
the acting Attorney General or
Rosenstein or does it come from you or
can it come from either I'm not gonna
discuss
and any other alternatives Thank You mr.
Muller disappear Thank You mr. chairman
mr. Muller I think I can say without
fear of contradiction that you're the
greatest patriot in this room today and
I want to thank you for being here thank
you you um said in your report and I'm
gonna quibble with your words that the
Russian intervention was sweeping and
systematic I would quibble with that
because I don't think it was just an
intervention I think it was an invasion
and I don't think it was just sweeping
and systematic I think it was sinister
and scheming and having said that one of
my colleagues earlier here referred to
this Russian intervention as a hoax and
I'd like to get your comment on that on
page 26 of your report you talked about
the internet research agency and how
tens of millions of US persons became
engaged with the posts that they made
that there were some 80,000 posts on
Facebook that Facebook itself admitted
that a hundred and twenty six million
people had probably seen the posts that
were put up by the internet research
agency that they had 3,800 Twitter
accounts and had designed more than a
hundred and seventy five thousand tweets
that probably reached one point four
million people the internet research
agency was spending about 1.25 million
dollars a month on all of this social
media in the United States in what I
would call an invasion in our country
would you agree that it was not a hoax
that the Russians were engaged in trying
to impact our election absolutely
that was not a hoax the indictments we
were turned against the Russians two
different ones were substantial and in
their scope using that let's go for it
again and I think one of the
we have underplayed to a certain extent
and that aspect of our investigation
that has and would have long-term damage
to the United States that we need to
move quickly to address thank you for
that I'd like to drill down on that a
little bit more the internet research
agency actually started in 2014 by
sending over staff as tourists I guess
to start looking at where they wanted to
engage and there are many that suggest
and I'm interested in your opinion as to
whether or not Russia is presently in
the United States looking for ways to
impact the 2020 election I can't speak
to that that would be in levels of
classification all right let me ask you
this
oftentimes we engage in these hearings
we forget the forest for the trees you
have a very large report here of over
400 pages most Americans have not read
it we have read it actually the FBI age
yesterday said he hadn't read it which
was a little discouraging but on behalf
of the American people I want to give
you a minute and 39 seconds to tell the
American people what you would like them
to glean from this report well we spent
substantial time assuring the integrity
of the report understanding that it
would be our living a message to those
who come after us but it also is a
signal a flag to those of us who have
some responsibility in this area to
exercise over those responsibilities
swiftly and don't let this problem
continue to linger as it has over so
many years all right you didn't take the
whole amount of time so I'm gonna yield
the rest of my time to the Chairman I
thank the gentleman for yielding dr.
Muller I wanted to ask you about
conspiracy generally a conspiracy
requires an offer of something illegal
the acceptance of that offer in an overt
act in furtherance of it is that correct
correct and Don Jr was made aware that
the Russians were offering dirt on his
opponent correct I don't know that for
sure but one would assume at the meeting
and and when you say that you would love
to get that help that would constitute
an acceptance of the offer it's a
wide-open request and it would certainly
be evidence of an acceptance if you say
when somebody offers you something
illegal you say I would love it that
would consider the considered evidence
of an acceptance
okay stay away from any addressing one
particularly situations well this
particular situation well I'll have to
continue in a bit now yield to mr.
Stewart the smaller it's been a long day
thank you for being here I do have a
series of important questions for you
but before I do that I want to take a
moment to emphasize something that my
friend mr. turner has said I've heard
many people state no person is above the
law and many times recently they had not
even the president which i think is
blazingly obvious to most of us I'm
having a little problem hearing it sir
is this better
that is better thank you I want you know
I agree with this statement that no
person is above the law but there's
another principle that we also have to
defend and that is the presumption of
innocence and I'm sure you agree with
this principle though I think the way
that your office phrased some parts of
your report it does make me wonder I
have to be honest with you for going on
three years innocent people have been
accused of very serious crimes including
treason accusations made even here today
they have had their lives disrupted and
in some cases destroyed by false
accusations for which there is
absolutely no basis other than some
people desperately wish that it was so
but your report is very clear no
evidence of conspiracy no evidence of
coordination and I believe we owe it to
these people who have been falsely
accused including the president and his
family to make that very clear mr.
Miller the credibility of your report is
based on the integrity of how it is
handled and there's something that I
think bothers me
other Americans I'm holding here in my
hand a binder of 25 examples of leaks
that occurred from the special counsels
office from those who associated with
your work dating back to as early as a
few weeks after your inception in the
beginning of your work and continuing up
to just a few months ago all of these
all of them have one thing in common
they were designed to weaken or to
embarrass the president every single one
never wasn't leaked that you'd found no
evidence of collusion never wasn't
leaked that the steel dossier was a
complete fantasy nor that it was funded
by the Hillary Clinton campaign I could
go on and on mr. Muller are you aware of
anyone from your team having given
advance knowledge of the raid on Roger
Stone's home to any person or the press
including CNN I'm not going to talk
about specifics I will mention but talk
for a moment about persons who become
involved in an investigation and the
understanding that in a lengthy thorough
investigation some persons will be under
a cloud that they should not be under a
cloud and one of the reasons for
emphasizing as I have the speed of an
election or not an election to speed of
an investigation is that so those
persons who are disrupted as a result of
I appreciate that but I do have a series
with the result of that investigation
thank you and you're right it is a cloud
and it's an unfair cloud for dozens of
people but to my point are you aware of
anyone providing information to the
media regarding the radar Roger stones
home including CNN I'm not gonna speak
to that okay mr. Miller you sent a
letter dated March 27th to attorney
general bar in which you claimed the
Attorney General's mammals Congress did
not fully capture the context your
report you stated earlier today that
response was not authorized did you make
any effort to determine who leaked this
confidential letter no and I'm not
certain this is a letter of March 27th
yes sir okay I'm not certain when it was
publicized I didn't know it was
publicized but I do not believe we would
be responsible for the leaks well I do I
do believe that we have done
a good job and assuring that no leaks
occur we have 25 examples here of where
you did not do a good job not you sir
I'm not accusing you at all but where
your office did not do a good job in
protecting this information one more
example do you know anyone who
anonymously made claims to the press
that attorney general bars March 24th
letter to Congress had been
misrepresented or misrepresented your
the basis of your report and what was
the question do you know who anonymously
made claims to the press that attorney
general bar is March 24th letter to
Congress had misrepresented the findings
of your report no sir given these
examples as well as others you must have
realized that leaks we're coming from
someone associated with a special
counsel's office but I'd like to ask you
I do not believe that well well sir this
was your work you're the only one your
office is the only one who had
information regarding this it had to
come from your office putting that aside
which leads me to my final question did
you do anything about it
from the outset we've undertaken to make
certain that we minimize the possibility
of leaks and I think we were to success
all over the tower over the two years
that we were in operation well I wish
you'd been more successful sir I think
it was disruptive to the American people
my time has expired I yield back mr.
Quigley thank miss chairman director
thank you for being here this too shall
pass earlier today and throughout the
day you have stated the policy that a
seated president cannot be indicted
correct right and upon questioning this
morning you were asked could that could
a president be indicted after their
service correct yes and your answer was
that they could good doctor please speak
into the microphone sorry thank you so
they could the follow-up question that
should be concerning is what if a
president serves beyond the statute of
limitations I don't know the answer to
that one would it not indicate
that if the statute of limitations on
federal crimes such as this or five
years that a president who serves his
second term is therefore under the
policy above the law I'm not certain I
would agree with the I'm not certain I
would agree with the conclusion I'm not
certain that I can see the sensibility
that you suggest but the statute doesn't
tall is that correct I don't know
specifically it it clearly doesn't and I
just want as the American public is
watching this and perhaps learning about
many of these for the first time we need
to consider that and that the other
alternatives are perhaps all that we
have but I appreciate your your response
earlier in questioning someone mentioned
that it was a question involving whether
anyone in the Trump political world
publicized the emails whether or not
that was a case I just want to refer to
volume 1 page 60 where we learned that
Trump jr. publicly tweeted a link to the
leak of stolen Podesta emails in October
of 2016
you're familiar with that so that would
at least be a republishing of this
information would it would it not I'm
not certain I would agree with that
director Pompeo assess WikiLeaks in one
point as a hostile intelligence service
giving your law enforcement experience
in your knowledge of what licky leaks
did here in what they do generally would
you assess that to be accurate or
something similar how would you assess
me what WikiLeaks does absolutely and
they are currently under indictment it's
really a sergeant but would it be fair
to describe them as you would agree with
mr. director Pompeo at let's when he
what he was when he made that remark
that it's a hostile intelligence service
correct if we could put up slide six
this just came out WikiLeaks I loved
WikiLeaks Donald Trump October 10th 2016
this wikileaks stuff is unbelievable it
tells you the inner heart you got to
read it Donald Trump October 12 2016
this WikiLeaks is like a treasure trove
Donald Trump October 31st 2016
boy I love reading those wiki leaks
Donald Trump November 4th 2016
many of those quotes disturb you mr.
director I'm not certain I would say you
were asked well it's probably
problematic is an understatement in
terms of what it display displays in
terms of giving some I don't know hope
or some boost to what isn't should be
illegal activity volume 1 page 59 Donald
Trump jr. had direct electronic
communications with WikiLeaks during the
campaign period on October 3rd 2016
WikiLeaks sent another direct message to
Trump jr. asking you guys to help
disseminate a link alleging candidate
Clinton had advocated a drone to attack
Julian Assange Trump jr. right responded
that quote he had already done so same
question
this behavior at the very least
disturbing a reaction I just started
also and subject to investigation could
it be described as aiding comfort to a
hostile intelligence service sir I
wouldn't categorize that name with any
specificity I yield the balance to the
Chairman pleased not sure I can make
good use of 27 seconds but director I
think you made it clear that you think
it unethical to put it politely to tout
a foreign service like WikiLeaks
publishing stolen political documents
that presidential campaign certainly
calls for investigation thank you
director
we're to go now to mr. Crawford and then
after mr. Crawford's five minutes we'll
take a five or ten-minute break
Thank You mr. chairman Thank You mr.
Malla for being here days after your
appointment Peterson
texts about his concern that there's
quote no big they're there
in the Trump campaign investigation did
struck or anyone else who worked on the
FBI's investigation tell you that around
ten months into the investigation the
FBI still had no case for collusion who
can you repeat that Peter struck could
you I'm sorry can you move the
microphone closer sure there's there's a
quote attributed to Peter strike he
texted about his concern that there is
quote no big there there in the Trump
campaign investigation did he or anyone
else who worked on the FBI's
investigation tell you that around ten
months into the investigation the FBI
still had no case for collusion no it is
the Inspector General report correct
that the text messages from Peter struck
and Lisa pages phones from your office
were not retained after they left a
special counsel's office well I don't it
depends on what you're talking about the
investigation into those Peter struck I
went on for a period of time and I am
not certain what it encompasses it may
we'll have a cup of what your adverting
- okay let me move on just real quickly
did you ask the department to authorize
your office to investigate the origin of
the Trump Russia investigation I'm not
gonna get into that goes to internal
deliberations so the circumstances
surrounding the origin of the
investigation have yet to be fully
vetted then I'm certainly glad that
attorney general bar and US attorney
Donna Durham are looking into this
matter with that I'd like to yield the
balance of my time to the ranking member
Nunez I thank the gentleman for yielding
mr. Muller I want to make sure you're
aware of who Fusion GPS is fusion GPS is
a political operations firm that was
working directly for the Hillary Clinton
campaign and the Democrat National
Committee they produce the dossier so
they paid steal who then went out and
got the dossier and I know you don't
want to ask answer any dossier questions
so I'm not going there but
your report mentions Natalia of lesson
ischia sixty five times she meets in the
Trump Tower it's this infamous trump
tower meeting it's in your report you've
heard many of the Democrats refer to it
today
the meeting was shorter than twenty
minutes I believe is that correct I
think what we have in our report
reflects it was about that length so do
you know so fusion GPS the main actor of
fusion GPS the president of the company
or the owner of the company was a guy
named Glenn Simpson who's working for
Hillary Clinton
Glenn Simpson do you know how many times
Glenn Simpson met with Natalia of lesson
skya myself no would it surprise you
that the Clinton campaign dirty ops arm
met with Natalia of lesson Ischia
more times than the Trump campaign did
well this is an area that I'm not gonna
get into as I indicated at the outset
did you ever interview Glenn Simpson
again I'm gonna pass on that
according to I'm gonna change topics
here according to notes from the State
Department official Kathleen Cadillac
Christopher still told her that former
Russian intelligence head Truman the
cough and Putin advisor Surkov were
sources for the steel dossier now
knowing that these are not getting into
whether these sources were real or not
real was there any concern that there
could have been disenfranchised
as I said before this is an area that I
cannot speak to is that because you're
it's not in the report or you're just or
because of them ongoing deliberations
other proceedings like okay
when Andrew Weissman and Zhanna
Ahmed joined your team were you aware
that Bruce or Department of Justice top
official directly briefed the dossier
allegations to them in the summer of
2016
again I'm not okay to speak to that
issue come before you have arrested
George papadopolis in July of 2017 he
was given $10,000 in cash in Israel do
you know who gave him that cash again
it's outside our but and questions such
as that should go to the FBI or
Department but it involved your
investigation
it involved persons involved in my
investigation Thank You mr. chairman we
will stand in recess for five or ten
minutes please folks remain your seats
allow the director mr. Sedley to exit
the chamber
[Music]
when he comes back
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
MIDI will come to order
thank you sir like a director mr.
swallow you recognized Thank You
director molar is a prosecutor you would
agree that if a witness or suspect lies
or obstructs or tampers with witnesses
or destroys evidence during an
investigation that generally that
conduct can be used to show a
consciousness of guilt would you agree
with that yes let's go through the
different people associated with the
Trump campaign and this investigation
who lied to you and other investigators
to cover up their disloyal and
unpatriotic conduct if we could put
exhibit 8 up director molar I'm showing
you campaign chairman Paul Manafort
political adviser Roger stone deputy
campaign manager Rick gates national
security adviser Michael Flynn Donald
Trump's personal attorney Michael Cohen
and foreign policy adviser George
papadopolis these six individuals have
each been charged convicted or lied to
your office or other investigators is
that right
yes although I look askance at mr. stone
because he is he he is in a different
case here in DC so National Security
Advisor Flynn lied about discussions
with Russian ambassador related to
sanctions is that right that's correct
Michael Cohen lied to this committee
about Trump Tower Moscow is that correct
yes George papadopolis the president's
senior foreign policy adviser lied to
the FBI about his communications about
Russia's possession of dirt on Hillary
Clinton is that right yes the
president's campaign chairman Paul
Manafort lied about meetings that he had
was someone with ties to Russian
intelligence sector that's true
and your investigation was hampered by
Trump campaign officials use of
encryption communications is that right
we believe that to be the case you also
believe to be the case that your
investigation was hampered by the
deletion of electronic messages is that
correct it would be yes generally any
case would be if those kinds of
communications are are used for example
you noted that deputy campaign manager
Rick Gates who shared internal campaign
polling data with the person with ties
to Russian intelligence at the direction
of mana Ford that mr. gates deleted
those communications on a daily basis is
that right I think you were say I don't
know specifically but if it's in the
report then I support it
that's right director it's volume 1 page
136 thank you in addition to that other
information was inaccessible because
your office determined it was protected
by attorney-client privilege is that
correct that is true that would include
that you do not know whether
communications between Donald Trump and
his personal attorneys Jay Sekulow Rudy
Giuliani and others discourage witnesses
from cooperating with the government is
that right that guy talked to that that
would also mean that you can't talk to
whether or not pardons were dangled
through the president's attorneys
because the shield of attorney-client
privilege no I'm not going to discuss
that did you want to interview Donald
Trump jr. and I'm not gonna discuss that
did you subpoena Donald Trump jr. and
I'm not going to discuss that did you
want to interview the president yes
director Moeller on January 1st 2017
through March 2019
Donald Trump met with Vladimir Putin
Putin in person six times called him ten
times and exchanged four letters with
him between that time period how many
times did you meet with Donald Trump I'm
not gay he did not meet with you in
person is that correct they did not as a
result of Lies deletion of text messages
obstruction in witness tampering is it
fair to say that you were unable to
fully assess the scope and scale of
Russia's interference in the 2016
election and Trump's role in that
interference I'm not turned I would
adopt that
a characterization in total there may be
pieces of it they're accurate but not in
total but you did state in volume 1 page
10 that while this report embodies
factual and legal determinations the
office believes it to be accurate and
complete to the greatest extent possible
given these identified gaps the office
cannot rule out the possibility that the
unavailable information would shed
additional light is that correct that is
correct it we don't know what we don't
know why is it so important that
witnesses cooperate and tell the truth
in an investigation like this as a
testimony of the witnesses goes to the
heart of just about any criminal case
you have thank you and mr. chair and I'd
yield back and thank you director moment
mr. phonic you mr. chairman mr. Muller
as Special Counsel did you review
documents related to the origin of the
counterintelligence investigations at
the Trump campaign on occasion was the
steal dossier one of those documents
that was reviewed and I can't discuss
that case I'm just asking a process
question have you read the steal dossier
and again I'm not gonna spawn to that
you were tasked as special counsel to
investigate whether there was collusion
between Russia and the Trump campaign
associates to interfere with the 2016
election and the FBI we know has
relevant documents and information
related to the opening of the CI
investigation were you and your team
permitted to access all of those
documents again I can't get into that
investigative what we can we collected
what we're doing with investigation
investigation materials let me ask it
this way was there any limitation in
your access to documents related to the
counterintelligence it's such a broad
question I really I have real trouble
answering it did the special counsel's
office undertake any efforts to
investigate and verify or disprove
allegations contained in the Steele
dossier again I can't respond the reason
I'm asking for the American public that
is watching it's a it's apparent that
the steal dossier formed part of the
basis to justify the FBI's
counterintelligence investigation into
Russian interference in the 20s
sixteen election as we know it was used
to obtain a FISA warrant on Carter page
this is why I'm asking these questions
did your office undertake any efforts to
identify Steele's sources or sub sources
again the same answer was were these
tasks referred to any other agencies
again I can't speak to it did your
office consider whether the Russian
government used steel sources to provide
steel with disinformation yeah I can't
speak to that I understand I'm asking
these questions just for the record so
thanks for your patience
shifting gears here did any member of
the special counsels office staff travel
overseas as part of the investigation
yes but I can't go further than that I'm
gonna ask to which countries and I can't
answer that do they meet with foreign
government officials again it's out of
our out of our bailiwick did they meet
with foreign private citizens again I
have the same response did they seek
information about a US citizen or any US
territory that I cannot go to thank you
for answering on the record these are
important questions for the American
public and were hopeful that the IG is
able to answer these questions I will
yield the balance of my time to the
ranking member for yielding mr. Muller I
want to go back to we started off with
Joseph Mifsud who's at the center of
this investigation he appears in your
report a dozen times or more he really
is the epicenter he's at the origin of
this he's the man who supposedly knows
about Clinton's emails you've seen on
the screen the Democrats have can you
put up all the prosecution's that you
made against Trump campaign officials
and and others but I'm I'm struggling to
understand why you didn't indict Joseph
Mifsud
who seems to be the man in the middle of
all of this well III think you
understand that you cannot get into
either classified or law enforcement
information without a rationale for
doing it and I have said on going to be
able to say with regard to mr. mitsuna
were you aware of
Kathleen Cadillacs involvement that she
had met with miss Steele the State
Department official yet I can't respond
to that question to outside my
jurisdiction come the Carter page FISA
warrant was was we have the last time it
was react was under under your watch so
you did you were you in the approval
process of that last time that the
Carter page warrant was well I can't
speak specifically about that warrant
but if you ask or was I in the approval
chain the answer's no okay that's very
helpful
Thank You mr. moon Thank You mr.
chairman yield back mr. Castro Thank You
chairman Thank You Special Counsel
Moeller for your testimony and for your
service to our country
Donald Trump over the years has
surrounded himself with some very shady
people people that lied for him people
had covered up for him people had helped
him enrich himself I want to talk
specifically about one of those
instances that's in your report
specifically let's turn to the Trump
Tower Moscow project which you described
in your report as quote as a quote
highly lucrative deal for the Trump
Organization is that right I would have
to look at the quote from The Observer
if you have it sure it's on volume 2
page 135 it's described as highly
lucrative
okay I have it sure have it thank you
sir
yeah no problem your office prosecuted
Michael Cohen and Michael Cohen was
Donald Trump's lawyer for lying to this
committee about several aspects of the
Trump organizations pursuit of the Trump
Tower Moscow deal is that right correct
according to your report Cohen lied to
quote minimize links between the project
and Trump unquote and to quote stick to
the party line unquote in order not to
contradict Trump's public message that
no connection existed between Trump and
Russia is that right that's an yes
that's correct
now when you're talking about the party
line here the party line in this case if
I can interject what they I should have
said the outset if it was in the report
and consequently I do believe it to be
true thank you the party line in this
case was that the deal ended in January
2016 in other words they were saying
that the deal ended in January 2016
before the Republican primaries in truth
though the deal extended to June 2016
when Donald Trump was already the
presumptive Republican nominee is that
correct that's correct the party line
was also that Cohen discussed the deal
with Trump only three times when in
truth they discussed it multiple times
is that right also true in the basis for
part of the basis for the play that he'd
that he entered for a line to this
entity thank you and thank you for
prosecuting that the party line was also
that Cohen and Trump never discussed
traveling to Russia during the campaign
when in truth they did discuss it is
that right that's accurate and the party
line was at Cohen never received a
response from the Kremlin to his
inquiries about the Trump Tower Moscow
deal in fact Cohen not only received a
response from the come from the Kremlin
to his email but also had a lengthy
conversation with a Kremlin
representative who had a detailed
understanding of the project is that
right
if it's in if it's in the report that is
a current resident recitation of that
piece of the report so you have to you
have the candidate Trump at the time
saying he had no business dealings with
Russia his lawyer who was lying about it
and then the Kremlin who during that
time was talking to president Trump's
lawyer about the deal is that right I
can't adopt your characterization not
only was Cohen lying on Trump's behalf
but so was the Kremlin on August 30th
2017
two days after Cohen submitted his false
statement to this committee claiming
that he never received a response to his
email to the Kremlin Vladimir Putin's
press secretary told reporters that the
Kremlin left the email unanswered that
statement by Putin's press secretary was
false wasn't it I can't speak to that
although it was write widely reported in
the press again I can't speak to that
particularly if it was if it was
dependent upon media sources but it was
consistent with the lie that Cohen had
made to the committee is that right I'm
not certain I could go that far so Cohen
president Trump and the Kremlin were all
telling the same lie I defer to you on
that I can't be again in the details a
special counsel Moeller I want to ask
you something that's very important to
the nation did your investigation
evaluate whether President Trump could
be vulnerable to blackmail by the
Russians because the Kremlin knew that
Trump and his associates lied about
connections to Russia related to the
Trump Tower deal I can't speak to that
are you aback chairman mr. hurt Thank
You mr. chairman director Muller you've
you've been asked many times afternoon
about collusion obstruction of justice
and in Pietschmann and the steel dossier
and I don't think your answers are going
to change if I ask you about those
questions so I'm going to ask about a
couple of press stories because a lot of
what the American people have received
about this I'm have been on press
stories and some of that has been wrong
and some of that some of those press
stories have been accurate
on April 13th 2018 McClatchy reported
that you had evidence Michael Cohen made
a secret trip to Prague during the 2016
presidential election I think he told
the one of the committees here in
Congress that was incorrect is that
story true I can't I can't go into it
got you on October 31st 2016 slate
published a report suggesting that a
server at Trump Tower was secretly
communicating with Russia's Alfa Bank
and I quote akin to what criminal
syndicates do do you know if that story
is true do not do not you do now whether
it's true so did you not investigate
these allegations which are suggestive
of potential Trump Russia because I
believe not true doesn't mean it would
not be investigated it may well have
been investigated although it my belief
at this point it's not true good copy
thank you as a former CIA officer I want
to focus on something I think both sides
of the political aisle can agree on that
is how do we prevent Russian
intelligence and other adversaries from
doing this again and after overseeing in
counterintelligence operations for 12
years as FBI and director and then
investigating what the Russians have
done in the 2016 election you've seen
tactics techniques and results of
Russian intelligence operations our
committee made a recommendation that the
FBI should improve its victim
notification process when a person
entity or campaign has fallen victim to
active measures of TAC would you agree
with this with this it sounds like a
worthwhile endeavor I will tell you
though that the ability of our
intelligence agencies to work together
in this arena is perhaps more important
than that and adopting whatever and I'm
not that familiar with the legislation
but whatever legislation will encourage
us working together by us I mean the FBI
CIA NSA and the rest it should be
pursued aggressively early
who do you think should be responsible
within the federal government to counter
a disinformation no longer than the
federal government sorry but you have
you've had a long storied career and I
don't think there's anybody who better
understands the threat that we are
facing than you do you do you have an
opinion as a former FBI officer as to as
to who should be coordinating points
within the federal government on how to
deal with I don't want to wade in those
waters a good copy I'm one of the most
striking things in your report is that
the internet research agency not only
undertook a social media campaign in the
US but they were able to organize
political rallies after the election our
our Committee issued a report and
insight on saying that Russian active
measures are growing with frequency and
intensity and including their expanded
use of groups such as the IRA and these
groups posed a significant threat to the
United States and our allies in upcoming
elections would you agree with that yes
in fact one of their areas that we have
to look at there are many more companies
are now companies many more countries
are developing capability to replicate
what the Russians had done you you
alluded to making sure the other all the
elements of the federal government
should be working together do you have a
suggestion on a strategy to do that to
counter desist information not
overarching is this in your
investigation that you think that this
was a single attempt by the Russians to
get involved in our election or did you
find evidence to suggest they'll try to
do this again oh it wasn't a single
attempt they're doing it as we sit here
and they expect to do it during the next
campaign director Muller I appreciate
your time and indulging us here in
multiple committees and I yield back to
the ranking member if he has I yield
back to the Chairman
mr. heck director Miller I'd like to go
to the motives behind the Trump campaign
encouragement and acceptance of help
during the election obviously a clear
motivation was to help them in a what
would turn out to be a very close
election but there was another key
motivation and that was frankly the
desire to make money I always try to
remember what my dad who never had the
opportunity to go beyond the eighth
grade taught me which is that I should
never ever underestimate the capacity of
some people to cut corners and even more
in order to worship and chase the
almighty buck and this is important
because I think it in fact does go to
the heart of why the Trump campaign was
so unrelentingly intent on developing
relationships with the Kremlin so let's
quickly revisit one financial scheme we
just discussed which was the Trump Tower
in Moscow we indicated earlier that it
was a lucrative bill Trump in fact stood
he and his company to earn many millions
of dollars on that deal did they not
serve and Cohen mr. Cohen his attorney
testified before this committee that
President Trump believed the deal
required Kremlin approval is that
consistent with what he told you I'm not
certain whether it's mr. Trump himself
or others associated with that
enterprise that had discussed the
necessity of having the input from the
state via the Russian government in
order to afford to go forward
successfully isn't it also true that
Donald Trump viewed his presidential
campaign as he told top campaign aides
that the campaign was an infomercial for
for the Trump Organization and his
properties I'm not familiar with that
and let's turn to Trump campaign chair
Paul Manafort did in fact your
investigation find any evidence that man
afore intended to use his position as
Trump's campaign chair for his own
personal financial benefit I all say
there was some indication of that but I
won't go further I think you'll find it
on page 135 of volume 1
during the transition Trump son-in-law
Jared Kushner met with Sergey Gourcuff
the head of a Russian owned bank that
was under is under US sanctions and
according to the head of the bank he met
with Kushner in his capacity as CEO of
Kushner companies to discuss business
opportunities is that correct sir I'm
not certain
it was about that let me just put it
that way
it was asserted thusly in your report
volume 1 160 and pages 161 and 162 your
report notes that at the time Kushner
companies were trying to renegotiate a
billion with a be a billion dollar lease
of their flagship building at six six
six Fifth Avenue correct I'm not
familiar with those financial
arrangements also on page 162 where
Kushner companies that was asserted had
dead applications coming due on the
company Eric Prince a supporter close to
Trump as a warrior unit administrator I
just support her I was yes he met in the
Seychelles during the transition with
Kiril demetria who was the head of a
sanctioned Russian government investment
arm which had close ties to Vladimir
Putin correct sir yes your investigation
determined that mr. Prince had not known
nor conducted business with Dmitri F
before Trump won the election correct
I defer to the report on that yet it
does and yet prince who had connections
to top administration trump
administration officials met with
dimitri f during the transition period
to discuss business opportunities among
other things but it wasn't just Trump
and his associates who were trying to
make money off this deal nor hide it nor
lie about it Russia was - that was the
whole point to gain relief from
sanctions which would hugely benefit
their incredibly wealthy
oligarchs for example sanctions relief
was discussed at that June 9th meeting
in the Trump Tower was it not sir yes it
was not a main subject for discussion
Trump administration National Security
Advisor designate Michael Flynn also
discussed sanctions in a secret
conversation with the Russian ambassador
did he not correct
so to summarize Donald Trump Michael
Cohen Paul Manafort Jared Kushner Eric
Prince and others in the Trump orbit all
tried to use their connections with the
Trump Organization to profit from Russia
which was openly seeking relief from
sanctions is that true sir I'm not yep
I'm not sure I'm not gonna adopt what
you like I will and I'd further assert
that was not only dangerous it was on
American greed corrupts greed corrupts
and it is a terrible foundation for
developing American foreign policy mr.
Ratcliffe director Muller given your
constraints on what you're able or
allowed to answer with respect to
counterintelligence matters or other
matters that are currently open and
under investigation you're not going to
be able to answer my remaining questions
so I thank you for your courtesies in
the answers that you have given to my
prior questions and I do thank you for
your extraordinary career and record of
service and yield the balance of my time
to the ranking member thank you
Thank You mr. Ratcliffe and mr. Muller
let me associate my words with mr.
Ratcliffe and a few more questions I
want to clean up a little bit about the
Eric prince Seychelles meeting so Eric
prince testified before this committee
that he was surveilled by the US
government and the information from this
surveillance was leaked to the press did
you investigate whether prince was
surveilled and whether classified
information on him was
illegally leaked to the media you say
did you or will you well I know you
can't no you're not going can't join
back up in the ranks but but did you
refer were you aware that you know
prince has made these allegations that
he was surveilled he's concerned that
there were leaks about this surveillance
did you make any referrals about these I
can't get I get in discussion on it come
I also want a general Flynn I know you
came after the leak of his phone call
with the Russian ambassador your time at
at FBI it would be a major scandal
wouldn't it for the leak of the National
Security Adviser and anyone I can't I
can't about that I thought this is did
you report named any people who were
acting as US government informants or
sources without disclosing that fact I
can't answer that come on
volume 1 page 133 of your report you
state that Konstantin column mnek has
ties to Russian intelligence his names
came up quite often today but your
report omits to mention that column Nick
has long-term relationships with US
government officials including our own
State Department I can't be I can't get
into that I know it's not in the report
but you know if column Nick is being
used in the report to say that he was
possibly some type of Russian Russian
agent I think it is important for this
committee to know if column Nick has
ties to our own State Department which
it appears that he that he does again
it's the same territory that I'm loath
to get into um you were asked this
earlier about
Trump attorney John Dowd that pieces of
his phone call were omitted from the
report it was what mr. Dowd calls a
sculpt Ettore evidence be concerned
about I'm not certain I would agree with
that characterization I think I said
that before yes an American citizen from
the Republic of Georgia who your report
miss identifies as a Russian claims that
your report omitted parts of a text
message he had with Michael Cohen about
stopping the flow of compromising tapes
of Donald Trump and the omitted portions
he says he did not know what the tapes
actually showed was that portion of the
exchange left out of the report for a
reason no we got an awful lot into the
report but we did not get every
intersection or conversation and like so
I am not familiar with that particular
episode you're talking about Thank You
mr. I want to thank you mr. chairman mr.
Welch director Muller did you find there
was no collusion between the Trump
campaign and Russia well we don't use
the word collusion the word we usually
uses the but not not collusion but one
of the other
terms that that fills in when collusion
is not not used in any of that the we
decided not to use the word collusion in
as much as it has no relevance to the
criminal law arena the term is
conspiracy that you get to you that's a
conspiracy exactly right you help me
I'll help you
thank you it's an agreement thank you
and in fact you had to then make a
charging decision after your
investigation where unless there was
enough evidence to prove beyond a
reasonable doubt you wouldn't make a
charge correct generally that's the case
but making that decision does not mean
your investigation failed to turn up
evidence of conspiracy absolutely
correct and in fact I'll go through some
of the significant findings that your
exhaustive investigation made you found
as I understand it that from May 2016
until the end of the campaign campaign
chairman mr. Manafort gave private
polling information to Russian agents
correct yep I will
and your thank you and your
investigation found that in June 2016
Donald Trump jr. made an arrangement to
meet at Trump Tower along with Jared
Kushner and others expecting to receive
dirt and the Hillary Clinton campaign
correct correct and you found in your
investigation that in July 27th a
candidate Trump called on Russia to hack
Hillary Clinton's email something that
for the first time they did about five
hours later correct that's correct and
you also found that on August 2nd mr.
Manafort met with a person tied to
Russian intelligence mr. clinic and gave
him internal campaign strategy aware
that Russia was intending to do a
misinformation social media campaign
correct on certain of the tie
but the fact of that meeting you of the
meeting took place as a factor in your
investigation as I understand it also
found that in the late summer of 2016
the Trump campaign in fact devised its
strategy and messaging around WikiLeaks
releases of materials that were stolen
from the Democratic National Committee
correct is that from the report yes it's
according to mr. gates yes yes thank you
and you also talked earlier about the
finding in your investigation that in
September and October of 2016 Donald
Trump jr. had email communications with
WikiLeaks now indicted about releasing
information damaging to the Clinton
campaign correct
true so so I I understand you made a
decision prosecutorial decision that
this would not rise to proof beyond a
reasonable doubt but I asked if you
share my concern my concern is if we
established a new normal from this past
campaign that is going to apply to
future campaigns so that if any one of
us running for the US House any
candidate for the US Senate any
candidate for the presidency of the
United States aware that if hostile
foreign power is trying to influence an
election has no duty to report that to
the FBI or other authorities I hope go
ahead I hope this is not the nor the new
normal but I fear it is and would in
fact have the ability without fear of
legal repercussion to meet with agents
of that foreign entity hostile to with
the American election I'm sorry what is
the question is that an apprehension
that you share with me yes and that
there would be no repercussions
whatsoever to Russia if they did this
again and as you've stated earlier as we
sit here they're doing it now is that
correct you're absolutely right do you
have any advice to
this Congress as together what we should
do to protect our electoral system and
accept responsibility on our part to
report to you or your successor when
we're aware of hostile foreign
engagement in our elections I would say
the basis the first line of defense
really is the ability of the various
agencies who have some piece of this to
I know I share information but share
expertise share targets and they use the
full resources that we have to address
this problem Thank You director Muller I
yield back
mr. Maloney tamela thank you I know it's
been a long day and I want to make clear
how much respect I have for service and
for your extraordinary career and I want
you to understand my questions in that
context sir I'm gonna be asking you
about Appendix C to to your report and
in particular the decision not to do a
sworn interview of the president it's
really the only subject I want to talk
to you about sir why didn't you subpoena
the president well at the outset after
we took over and initiated the
investigation if I could ask you to
speak in the mail but of course at the
outset after we took over the
investigation and began it and pursued
it quite obviously one of the things we
anticipated wanting to accomplish that
is getting having the interview of the
president we negotiated from with him
for a little over a year and I think
what you've inverted to and the appendix
lays out our expectations as a result of
those negotiations but finally when if
we were almost towards the end of our
investigation and we'd had little
success in pushing to get the interview
of the president we decided that that we
did not want to exercise the subpoena
powers because of the necessity of
expediting the end of the investigation
was that was that excuse me did you when
I was guys say the expectation was if we
did subpoenaed the president he would
fight the subpoena and we would be in
the midst of the investigation for a
substantial period of time right but but
as we sit here you've never had an
opportunity to to ask the president in
person questions under oath and so
obviously there must have been a
difficult decision and you're right
Appendix C lays that out and indeed I
believe you describe the the in-person
interview as vital that's your word and
of course you made clear you had the
authority and the legal justification to
do it as you point out you waited a year
you put up with a lot of negotiations
you made numerous accommodations which
you lay out so that he could prepare and
not be surprised I take it you were
trying to be fair to the president and
by the way you were going to limit the
questions when you got to written
questions to Russia only and in fact you
did go with written questions after
about nine months or right and and and
the president responded to those and you
have some hard language for what you
thought of those responses what did you
think of the president's written
responses mr. Muller it's certainly not
as useful as the interview would be in
fact in fact you you pointed out and by
my count there were more than 30 times
when the president said he didn't recall
he didn't remember no independent
recollection no current recollection and
I take it by your answer that it wasn't
as helpful that's why you used words
like incomplete imprecise inadequate
insufficient is that a fair summary of
what you thought of those written
answers that is a fair summary and I
approve resume that comes from their
report and yes sir and I asked this
respectfully by the way the president
didn't ever claim the Fifth Amendment
did he not talk to that well i from what
I can tell sir at one point it was vital
and then at what another point it wasn't
vital and my question to you is why did
it stop being vital and I can only think
of three explanations one is that
somebody told you you couldn't do it but
nobody told you you couldn't subpoena
the president is that right no we
understood we could subpoena the
president Rosenstein didn't tell you
Whittaker didn't tell you Barr didn't
tell you you couldn't mean we could
serve a subpoena so the only other
explanation well there's two others I
guess one that you just flinched that
you had the opportunity to do it you
didn't do it but but Sir you know
strike me as the kind of guy who
flinches hope well then the third
explanation I hope not to sir and the
third explanation I can think of is that
is that you didn't think you needed it
and in fact what caught my eye was page
13 on volume 2 where you said in fact
you had a substantial body of evidence
and you cite a bunch of cases there
don't you about how you often have to
prove intent to obstruct justice without
an in-person interview that's the kind
of nature of it and you and you and you
use terms like a substantial body of
evidence significant evidence of the
president's intent so my question sir is
did you have sufficient evidence of the
president's intent to obstruct justice
and is that why you didn't do the
interview there's a balance in other
words how much evidence you had that
satisfied the last element against how
much time are you willing to spend in
the courts litigating a the interview of
the president in this case you felt that
you had enough evidence of the
president's intent we had to make a
balanced decision in terms of how much
evidence we have compared to the length
of time it would take sir because I have
limited time you thought that if you
gave it to the Attorney General or to
this Congress that there was sufficient
evidence that it was better than that
delay can you state that again well that
it was better than the delay to present
the sufficient evidence your term of the
president's intent to obstruct justice
to the Attorney General and to this
committee isn't that why you didn't do
the interview the reason we didn't do
the interview is because of the length
of time that it would take to resolve
the issues attendant to that thank you
sir there's Demmings thank you so much
mr. chairman and director Muller thank
you so much for being a person of honor
and integrity thank you for your service
to the nation we are certainly better
for it director Muller I do want to
focus on the written responses that the
President did provide and the continued
efforts to lie and cover up what
happened during the 2016 election where
the president answers submitted under
oath yes
thank you they were were these all the
answers your office wanted to ask the
president about Russia interferes in the
2016 election so there were other yes
questions that you wanted to answer did
you analyze his written answers on
Russia interference to draw conclusions
about the president's credibility no it
was perhaps one of the factors but
nothing more than that it was one of the
factors so what did you determine about
the president's credibility and that I
can't get into director Muller I know
based on your decades of experience
you've probably had an opportunity to
analyze the krell availability of
countless witnesses but you weren't able
to do so with this witness
well with every witness particularly a
leading witness one assesses the
credibility day by day witnessed by
witness document by document and that's
what happened in this case so we started
with very little and by the end we thank
you well let's go through some of the
answers to take a closer look at his
credibility because it seems to me
director Weller that his answers were
not credible at all to some of president
Trump's incomplete answers relate to
Trump Tower of Moscow yes for example
did you ask the president whether he had
had at any time directed or suggested
that that discussions about Trump Moscow
project should cease should cease do you
have any citation yes we're still in
Appendix II Section 1 7 the first page
huh
as the president did not answer whether
he had at any time directed or suggested
that discussions about the Trump Moscow
project should cease but he has since
made public comments about this topic
okay and the question was did the
president deliver let me go into the
nest but did the president fully answer
that question in his written statement
to you about the Trump Moscow project
ceasing again in Appendix A and can you
direct me to the particular paragraph
your adverting to it would be Appendix C
- C 1
but let me move forward nine days after
he submitted his written answers didn't
the president say publicly that he quote
decided not to do the project unquote
and that is in your report I'd ask you
I'd ask you if you would to point out
the the particular paragraph that you
are okay we can move on did the
president answer your follow-up
questions
according to the report there were
follow-up questions because of the
president's incomplete answers about the
Moscow project
did the president answer your follow-up
questions either in writing or orally
and we're now in volume 2 page 150
through 151 no he did not in fact there
were many questions that you asked the
president that he simply didn't answer
isn't that correct true and there were
many answers that contradicted other
evidence you had gathered during the
investigation isn't that correct yes
director Morello for example the
president has written answers stated he
did not recall having advanced knowledge
of WikiLeaks releases is that correct I
think that's what he said but didn't
your investigation uncover evidence that
the President did in fact have advanced
knowledge of WikiLeaks
public releases of emails damaging to
his opponent and I can't get into that
area did your investigation determine
after very careful vetting of Rick Gates
and Michael coins that you found them to
be credible
we found the president to be credible
that you found gates and Cohen to be
credible in their statements about
WikiLeaks I'm not going to discuss okay
could you say director Morello that the
president was credible I can't answer
that question
director Marella isn't it fair to say
that the president is written answers
were not only inadequate and incomplete
because he didn't answer many of your
questions but where he did his answer
showed that he wasn't always being
truthful there I would say generally
generally director murder is one thing
for the president to lie to the American
people about you investigation falsely
claiming that you found known collusion
and no obstruction but is something else
altogether for him to get away with not
answering your questions and lying about
them and as a former law enforcement
officer of almost 30 years I find that a
disgrace to our criminal justice system
thank you so much I go back to the
Chairman mr. Krishna Murthy director
Muller thank you for your devoted
service to your country earlier earlier
today you described your report as
detailing a criminal investigation
correct yes yes director since it was
outside the purview of your
investigation your report did not reach
counterintelligence conclusions
regarding the subject matter of your
report that's true for instance since it
was outside your purview your report did
not reach counterintelligence
conclusions regarding any Trump
administration officials who might
potentially be vulnerable to compromise
or blackmail by Russia correct
those decisions probably were made in
the counter at the FBI but not in your
report correct not in our report we
advert to the the counter counter
intelligence goals of our investigation
which were secondary to any criminal
wrongdoing that we could find let's talk
about one administration official in
particular namely President Donald Trump
other than Trump Tower Moscow your
report does not address or detail the
president's financial ties or dealings
with Russia
correct correct similarly since it was
outside your purview your report does
not address the question of whether
Russian oligarchs engaged in money
laundering through any of the
president's businesses correct correct
and of course your office did not obtain
the president's tax returns which could
otherwise show foreign financial sources
correct to speak of that I'm not going
to speak to that in July 2017 the rep
the president said his personal finances
were off-limits or outside the purview
of your investigation and he drew a
quote-unquote red line around his
personal finances were the president's
personal finances outside the purview of
your investigation I'm not getting in
that were you instructed by anyone not
to investigate the president's personal
finances no mr. Muller I'd like to turn
your attention to counterintelligence
risks associated with lying individuals
can be subject to blackmail if they lie
about their interactions with foreign
countries correct crew for example you
successfully charged former national
security adviser Michael Flynn of lying
to federal agents about his
conversations with Russian officials
correct right since it was outside the
purview of your investigation your
report did not address how Flynn's false
statements could pose a national
security risk because the Russians knew
the falsity of those statements right I
cannot get into that mainly because
there are many elements of the FBI
they're looking at different aspects of
that issue currently currently thank you
as you noted in volume 2 of your report
Donald Trump repeated five times in one
press conference mr. mauler in 2016
quote I have nothing to do with Russia
of course Michael Cohen said Donald
Trump was not being truthful because at
this time Trump was attempting to build
Trump Tower Moscow your report does not
address whether Donald Trump was
compromised in any way because of any
potential false statements that he made
about Trump Tower Moscow correct that's
right I think that's right director
Muller I want to turn your attention to
a couple other issues
you've served as FBI director during
three presidential elections correct yes
and during those three presidential
elections you have never initiated an
investigation at the FBI looking into
whether a foreign government interfered
in our elections the same way you did in
this particular instance I would say I
personally know but the FBI coin
obviously has the outer you defense an
attack such as the Russians undertook in
2016 now director Muller is there any
information you'd like to share with
this committee that you have not so far
today well that's a broad question and I
take me a while to get an answer to if I
say no mr. Muller you said that every
American should pay very close attention
to the systematic and sweeping fashion
in which the Russians interfered in our
democracy are you concerned that we are
not doing enough currently to prevent
this from happening again
I'll speak generally and what I said in
my opening statement this morning and
here that no much more needs to be done
in order to protect against this
intrusions not just by the Russians but
others as well
thank you director you have to a five
minute or its remaining mr. Nunez and
myself mr. Nunez you were recognized mr.
Muller it's been a long day for you and
you've had a long great career I want to
thank you for your longtime service
starting in Vietnam obviously in the US
Attorney's Office Department of Justice
and the FBI and I want to thank you for
doing something you didn't have to do
you came here upon your own free will
and we appreciate your time today with
that I yield back
thank you sir dr. Muller I want to close
out my questions
turn to some of the exchange you had
with mr. Welsh a bit earlier I'd like to
see if we can broaden the aperture at
the end of the hearing from your
testimony today I gather that you
believe that knowingly accepting foreign
assistance during a presidential
campaign is an unethical thing to do and
a crime and a crime and to the given
certain circumstances and to the degree
that it undermines our democracy and our
institutions we can agree that it's also
unpatriotic true and wrong true the
standard of behavior for a presidential
candidate or any candidate for that
matter shouldn't be merely whether
something is criminal there should be
held to a higher standard you would
agree yeah I will not get into that
because it goes to the standards to be
applied by other institutions besides
ours I'm just referring to ethical
standards we should hold our elected
officials to a standard higher than mere
avoidance of criminality shouldn't we
absolutely you have served this country
for decades you've taken an oath to
defend the Constitution you hold
yourself to a standard of doing what's
right I would help you have I think we
can all see that and befitting the times
I'm sure your reward will be unending
criticism but we are grateful the need
to act in an ethical manner is not just
a moral one but when people act
unethically it also exposes them to
compromise particularly in dealing with
foreign powers is that true true because
when someone acts on ethically in
connection with a foreign partner that
foreign partner and later expose their
wrongdoing and extort them true and that
conduct that unethical conduct can be of
a financial nature if you have a
financial motive or an illicit business
dealing all right yes
but it also just involve deception if
you are lying about something that can
be exposed then you can be
blackmailed also true in the case of
Michael Flynn he was secretly doing
business with Turkey correct yes and
that could open him up to compromise
that financial relationship I presume he
also lied about his discussions with the
Russian ambassador and since the
Russians were on the other side of that
conversation they could have exposed
that could they not yes if a
presidential candidate was doing
business in Russia and saying he wasn't
Russians could expose that too could
they not I'd leave that to you well
let's let's look at Dmitry Peskov the
spokesperson for the Kremlin someone
that the Trump Organization was in
contact with to make that deal happen
your report indicates that Michael Cohen
had a long conversation on the phone
with someone from Dmitry Peskov office
presumably the Russians could record
that conversation could they not yes and
so if candidate Trump was saying I have
no dealings with the Russians but the
Russians had a tape recording they could
expose that could they not yes that's
the stuff of counterintelligence
nightmares is it not well it has to do
with counterintelligence and the need
for our strong counterintelligence
entity it does indeed and when this was
revealed that there were these
communications notwithstanding the
president's denials the president was
confronted about this and he said two
things first of all that's not a crime
but I think you and I have already
agreed that that shouldn't be the
standard right mr. Miller true and the
second thing he said was why should I
miss out on all those opportunities
I mean why indeed merely running a
presidential campaign why should you
miss out on making all that money was
the import of his statement we ever able
to ascertain whether Donald Trump still
intends to build that tower when he
leaves office not a question sir
yes were you able to ascertain because
he wouldn't answer your questions
completely
whether or if he ever ended that desire
to build that tower I'm not gonna
speculate on that if the president was
concerned that if he lost his election
he didn't want to miss out on that money
might he have the same concern about
losing his re-election on that money of
speculation the difficulty with this of
course is we are all left to wonder
whether the president is representing us
or his financial interests that cludes
my questions mr. Nunez do you have any
concluding remarks dr. Moore let me
close by returning to where I began
thank you for your service and thank you
for leading this investigation the facts
you set out in your report and have
elucidated here today tell a disturbing
tale of a massive Russian intervention
in our election of a campaign so eager
to win so driven by agreed that it was
willing to accept the help of a hostile
foreign power in a presidential election
decided by a handful of votes in a few
key states your work tells of a campaign
so determined to conceal their corrupt
use of foreign help that they risk going
to jail by lying to you to the FBI and
to Congress about it and indeed some
have gone to jail over such lies and
your work speaks of a president who
committed countless acts of obstruction
of justice that in my opinion and that
of many other prosecutors had it been
anyone else in the country they would
have been indicted
now withstanding the many things you
have addressed today and in your report
there were some questions you could not
answer given the constraints you're
operating under you would not tell us
whether you would have indicted the
president but for the OLC opinion that
you could not and so the Justice
Department will have to make that
decision when the president leaves
office both as to the crime of
obstruction of justice and as to the
campaign finance fraud steen that
individual one directed and coordinated
and for which Michael Cohen went to jail
you would not tell us
whether the president should be
impeached nor did we ask you since it is
our responsibility to determine the
proper remedy for the conduct outlined
in your report whether we decide to
impeach the president in the house or we
do not we must take any action necessary
to protect the country while he is in
office you would not tell us the results
or whether other bodies looked into
Russian compromise in the form of money
laundering so we must do so you would
not tell us whether the
counterintelligence investigation
revealed whether people still serving
within the administration pose a risk of
compromise and should never have been
given a security clearance so we must
find out we did not bother to ask
whether financial inducements from any
Gulf nations were influencing this u.s.
policy since it is the outside the four
corners of your report and so we must
find out but one thing is clear from
your report your testimony from director
Ray's statements yesterday the russians
massively intervened in 2016 and they
are prepared to do so again in voting
that is set to begin a mere eight months
from now the president seems to welcome
the help again and so we must make all
efforts to harden our elections
infrastructure to ensure there is a
paper trail for all voting to deter the
Russians from meddling to discover it
when they do to disrupt it and to make
them pay protecting the sanctity of our
elections begins however with the
recognition that accepting foreign help
is disloyal to our country unethical and
wrong we cannot control what the
Russians do not completely but we can
decide what we do and that this
centuries-old experiment we call
American democracy is worth cherishing
director Muller thank you again for
being here today
and before I adjourn I would like to
excuse you and mr. Sibley
everyone else please remain seated
this hearing is adjourned
[Music]
I was from that employees would randomly
go up at different times and be up on
the unit and we believe that he may have
accidentally felt behind the unit the
mother she kinda had an idea that he had
never left the no-frills I don't know
how she came up with that idea but you
know they were they were pretty upset
you don't hear about these type of cases
people found in walls especially in this
area so that's that would be the odd
part about it we have missing persons
all the time but you know this is just
unique
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]